[Music]
you may never have heard of
orsted inel next era or
first solar but they've emerged as hot
companies this year
as investment in renewable energy has
boomed
shares of the danish company orsted the
world's biggest offshore wind developer
have risen around 80
in 2020 and green energy companies have
outperformed their oil and gas
counterparts
stock market is a one indicator of of an
industry
but it shows that people expect that
renewable demand will increase
in the coming years which we see by the
way all around the world
globally clean energy investment is
expected to account for half of total
investment in the entire energy sector
in 2020
after years of relatively unpredictable
growth renewables are getting more
investment than ever
and it has to do with a pandemic an
unprecedented political push to reduce
carbon emissions
and the falling cost of green energy
the coronavirus crisis has shifted
investment away from fossil fuels
oil prices saw a historic drop in the
spring when global lockdown sapped
demand for oil and gas as people stopped
driving and flying
we looked at multiple indicators that
show that renewables are resilient to
this crisis
the whole energy sector declined by 40
percent in terms of the equity shares
this includes oil and gas companies
using those major utilities at the same
time we see that
wind and solar companies their share
doubled or more than doubled
on an average basis and in the wake of
the industry-wide slump
big oil firms like bp and total have
been making more commitments to green
energy
many analysts including jaime bahar the
international energy agency agree that
while demand for oil may see a rebound
in 2021
it's expected to wane in the coming
years meanwhile demand for renewable
energy is forecast to grow with wider
adoption of electric vehicles
and as countries around the world are
investing big to cut carbon emissions
and the election of joe biden gives the
industry a boost
when i think about climate change the
word i think of is
jobs during his campaign biden outlined
a 2
trillion dollar plan to fight climate
change and put the us on a path to a 100
percent clean energy economy
by 2050 all of this on top of his pledge
to rejoin the paris climate accord
so the u.s rejoining would have a
significant impact on clean energy
investing and green investing in general
because it would likely spur government
regulation all around the world
and likely private investment to build
up these projects
and fulfill these paris agreement
promises whether this lasts
in the eyes of investors will largely
come down to
the extent to which joe biden can
deliver on these promises
we can put millions of americans to work
modernizing water
transportation and energy infrastructure
to withstand the impacts of extreme
weather
when we think about renewable energy we
see american manufacturers american
workers
racing to lead the global market just
before biden was elected
next era energy the us's largest
renewable energy company
briefly topped the market valuation of
exxon mobil
a significant moment for renewables
producers
other global powers have also recently
doubled down on clean energy
with china the world's biggest polluter
even pledging to go carbon neutral by
2060
is the biggest climate commitment made
by any nation
the eu has tied coronavirus stimulus
money to green energy plans
and pledged around a third of its 1.8
trillion euro recovery fund to climate
initiatives
while investing specifically in wind
solar and batteries
in europe we have set our objective
to become the first carbon neutral
continent by 2050.
government commitments like these have
boosted shares of european utility
companies like inel and ibradrola
two global builders of green energy
projects so when you include these
big big big economies together you start
to see
a force behind the clean energy
transitions
these are maybe long-term targets but it
gives a signal
to investors that we will get there the
government
signal here is very very important
to give investors a possibility
of a future picture of the world
as investment grows and technology
advances the price of clean energy is
dropping
since 2010 the cost of solar power is
down 82
an estimated 90 percent of new
electricity generated in 2020 comes from
renewables
which are projected to be the world's
main energy source by 2050
we see this general trend that in most
countries in the world
solar and wind can offer cheaper prices
than fossil fuel alternatives for new
projects
the most difficult thing is to raise the
investment to put the money in the first
place which is very high
compared to other technologies but then
operate that plant
the cost is very low because wind is for
free solar is for free